pull it up on the screen number one seed  the Buffalo Bills at number two let's go  to Chief's Kingdom baby Kansas City 3C a  little spicy here the Baltimore Ravens  in Lamar Jackson I trust four seed  Tennessee Titans the three Wild Card  teams very very dangerous I've got the  Miami Dolphins Cincinnati Bengals in the  final seed AFC West getting another team  in there the number one seed in the NFC  y'all know who it is man it's Philly I'd  argue saying they're probably the best  team in the NFL Minnesota Vikings 2C San  Francisco 49ers they will be the three  seed the Bucks would be the four seed  Dallas Cowboys man 50 put it up there  Seattle Seahawks as a sixth seed behind  Geno Smith and the final seed on the NFC  side  New York y'all got one the Giants make  it to the playoffs baby the Giants are  back in the playoffs